olivier vous vous avez suivi
particulièrement le discours dans de joe
biden que faut-il en retenir en entendez
vladimir poutine parler de relations
constructives joe biden lui parler de
tonalité positive on est sur la même
tonalité justement oui effectivement
stéphanie c'est la première chose qu'on
peut retenir ce soir après ces deux
conférences de presse qui se sont
succédé à joe biden a parlé environ 45
minutes après son homologue russe
et bien c'est qu'ils en retiennent une
rencontre plutôt positif je vais y donne
a qualifié cet échange ces échanges de
très direct et il a précisé bien que
rien ne remplace le dialogue en tête à
tête il a aussi affirmé qu'il n'avait
rien contre la russie mais qu'il
privilégiait avant tout les intérêts
américains alors je vous propose
d'écouter plus généralement joe biden si
on état d'esprit
sur l'état d'esprit avec lequel il a
vécu cette rencontre il était important
de se rencontrer en personne pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune erreur aucune fausse
représentation en ce qui concerne ce que
je souhaitais communiqué j'ai fait ce
que je voulais faire premièrement j'ai
identifié des domaines de travail
pratique pour le du pays pour favoriser
nos intérêts mutuels pour nous mêmes et
pour le monde
deuxièmement communiquer de manière
directe directement que les états unis
réagiront à des actions qui sont contre
nos intérêts vitaux aussi deux alliés et
troisièmement énoncer clairement quelles
sont nos priorités quels sont nos
valeurs pour cool il entendu directement
de ma bouche et je dois vous dire que le
la tonalité de ses rencontres de plus de
quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive alors
une rencontre positive de façon générale
ça n'a pas empêché des deux hommes est
bien d'aborder les sujets qui fâchent
comme la sphère navalni à rolls elle a
suscité énormément de tensions ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois
alors pour le président américain il est
dit clairement que vladimir poutine
il a dit clairement à vladimir poutine
qu'ils s'opposaient au traitement
réservé à alexeï navalni l'a dit
également qu'il s'inquiétait de la
situation en biélorussie
parmi les gros dossiers qui ont été
évoqués on en parlait tout à l'heure
avec antoine claireaux c'est bien
évidemment celui de la cybersécurité
alors joe biden a déclaré avoir fait
part à son homologue que certaines
infrastructures ne devait jamais être
attaquée il a aussi précisé que les deux
pays avaient convenu de mandater des
experts afin d'encadrer un des experts
clés afin d'encadrer les pratiques par
naïveté j'ai parlé de cette idée que
certains a fracturé stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué pour hâter
la guinée de manière cybernétique ou
autre je lui donnais une liste si je
m'abuse je n'ai pas de moi mais il ya 16
entités spécifiques
16 entités définit comme relevant de
l'infrastructure sont fondamentales des
états unis les systèmes de l'eau ce
principe est fondamentale et cela doit
être étayé par la pratique les pays
responsables à prendre des mesures
contre les criminels qui prennent des
mesures de rançons sur leur propre
territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts des deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compressions de ce
qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui origine dans l'un ou
l'autre de nos pays''
et puis joe biden a comme vladimir
poutine a insisté sur le fait que les
deux puissances avaient eu une
responsabilité par rapport à la
stabilité dans le monde par exemple sur
le dossier nucléaire iranien
joe biden a dit à vladimir poutine qui a
que vladimir poutine avait convenu
s'investir pour que l'iran ne se dote
pas de l'armé nucléaire
et puis il y avait aussi cette question
des droits de l'homme
puisqu'on a vu le président américain
s'affiche et quelques jours avant la
rencontre et bien un peu comme le porte
parole des droits de l'homme c'est ce
qu'il disait notamment lors des
interviews accordés à des médias
américains
et bien sûr cette question il a répondu
également ce soir je vous propose de
l'écouter
j'ai dit au président poutine que mon
agenda n'est pas contre la russie ou
contre qui que ce soit d'autre
mon agenda et pour le peuple américain
pour lutter contre a que vides
reconstruire notre économie rétablir nos
relations au tour du monde avec nos amis
et alliés et protéger le peuple
américain
cela constitue ma responsabilité en tant
que président je lui ai également dit qu
aucun président des états unis ne peut
être honnête envers le peuple américain
s'il ne parle pas aux efforts pour
défendre nos valeurs démocratiques se
porter garant pour les valeurs
universelles de la liberté dont sont
dotés les hommes et les femmes selon
nous cela relève de l'adn de notre pays
dont
les droits humains figurant toujours sur
la table je lui ai dit il ne s'agit pas
simplement de s'en prendre à la russie
lorsqu'il viole les droits de l'homme
non cela relève de notre état du profond
comment est-ce que moi président des
états unis pourraient m'abstenir de
parler contre les violations des droits
de l'homme je le lui ai dit et pour
conclure on peut également retenir cette
phrase du président américain pour lui
et bien vladimir poutine ne cherche pas
la guerre froide voilà donc c'est avec
ces mots de joe biden que ce sommet
aujourd'hui cette tenue c'était la
première fois que les deux hommes en
tant que chef d'état se rencontrait
aujourd'hui ici à genève stéphanie merci
olivier de care en flex